hello everyone and welcome to a game a
lot of you have requested uh yesterday
uh it's a game between leela chester
zero and stockfish and if you guys did
not know this you'd probably think uh
this was uh adolf anderson on steroids
playing with the white pieces this game
is absolutely amazing and it is one of
the reasons i i don't show that many uh
engine games or neural network games on
my channel because these games are
extremely addictive and you will not be
able to get enough of them so this is
just uh uh one game and then we're back
to human chess maybe i'm going to throw
in a you know a game here and there but
it's very very dangerous to get hooked
on these these games so
let's check it out it's a variant of
chess called chess 960 where the pieces
are scrambled a little bit
but
i also think that uh it's very
interesting how the engines play such
positions because when you have humans
playing chess 960 and there are a lot of
chess 960 tournaments um nowadays for
example compared to five years ago uh
it's uh humans always try to get some
sort of a familiar uh background uh you
know
just just to get somewhere where they
feel comfortable they wanna castle the
safety they wanna uh play play like a
normal game of chess whereas here you'll
see it's a completely different story so
let's check it out that this is uh
this is a like
an amazing story so leela with the white
pieces opens with knight to g3 uh
stockfish replies with c5 so both
players uh controlling the center leela
with the knights uh uh stockfish with
the pawn and now already knights to h5
just going after that g7 pawn as it's
undefended so here queen to e5 defending
the pawn and attacking the knight on h5
and now g4 defending the knight
we have e6 preparing to get the bishop
into the game also if white moves the f
pawn also bishop to h4 might be an idea
so knights to d3 attacking the queen and
queen to g5 and now leela starts
attacking the black queen and you can
see how stockfish doesn't mind about
human principles uh as we often say
don't bring your queen out too early
here stockfish is playing exclusively
with the queen we've um after queen g5
we have e4 now preparing f4 uh and c4
now attacking the knight here we have f4
attacking the queen g6 and the queen to
f5 so what do you do here uh we capture
an f5 once e captures and now bishop to
h for delivering check leela blocks with
the bishop
and then now
capturing the bishop isn't all that
impressive because after captures and
captures it's uh not fun for this black
queen here for example if queen g5 we
can just castle and uh what do you play
here it's such a bad position for black
that uh it's hard to even find the move
if you try something like g6 to get the
knight away from there uh just knight e4
uh we attacked the queen and both of the
knights are now attacking f6 and that's
pretty much it queen here knight here
with check and the black is black is
terrible so instead after bishop to f2
we have queen to g5 and now what does
white play as lila's knight is hanging
on d3 well leela doesn't care leela just
castles kingside and says you are
welcome to grab the knight so stockfish
captures the knight and now bishop
captures an h for queen captures and now
even f6 uh grabbing control of that uh
king side and uh
if you don't develop the bishop at night
black can never castle king's side so
what do you play here you could capture
of course but then knight captures this
is just uh well uh it's it's bad but
both moves that stockfish can play are
bad but
stockfish chooses a closed structure he
plays g6 and now we have knight to g7
check king to d8 and now c captures on
d3 so just like that sacrifice the
knight on d3 now recapturing this but uh
what did ligla get in return well uh the
complete blockade of black's king side
so the rook cannot move the bishop
cannot move the knight cannot move so
how can you continue here and it's very
interesting that leela considers this
position to be a a 1.5 advantage for
white whereas stockfish considers it to
be an almost three advantage for white
so knight to d6 stockfish also needs to
get his pieces into the game and now
what do we always say when you play with
the white pieces what do you have to do
well of course you have to push b4 and
again uh breaking human principles a
little bit uh we often say that you
should not be expanding on the king side
as well as the queen side but engines
and neural networks have changed this
idea uh quite some time ago because now
we know it's actually perfectly fine to
push both on the king side and on the
queen side so queen g5 and now uh as the
d2 point is hanging we have queen to b2
but queen to b2 is also a very deadly
threat as you'll see we rook the c8 uh
stockfish gets the rook into the game
now comes a4 and knight to e8 now
offering a trade of knights but now
comes another brilliant move by leela
and that is h4 uh brilliant brilliant
move uh and uh uh okay it's also a
question for you uh
can black capture the h4 pawn feel free
to pause the video here and try to
figure out why black can or cannot
capture the h4 pawn while i give you a
couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on uh realizing that
the h4 pawn is most definitely off
limits and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show uh queen to d5 is
what stockfish played but just in case
you didn't find it if qh4 just queen e5
and that's it there's no defense against
queen to e7 you're gonna lose the rook
and it's a game over
so instead after h4 we have queen to d5
keeping an eye on that e5 square and now
g5 look at this beautiful blockade on
the king side
and it seems like the white king is
completely open but you know you just
don't care because black doesn't have
any pieces in the game and leela will
continue developing with tempo so here
knights to d6
bishop to f3 even offering another pawn
uh so queen captures on d3 and now rook
to a3 like i said uh otto thunderson on
steroids this is just amazing
development uh and now not moving the
queen but rather knight to c4 offering a
queen trade and now it's also very
interesting that stockfish considers
this as a 2.5 advantage for for white
whereas lila already considers it a six
point advantage for white so here leela
very gladly trades rook captures knight
captures and now rook to d5 uh so what
do you play do you capture the a4 pawn
uh and interestingly uh white uh
is still down a piece but uh
black cannot move the rook the bishop or
the knight so here we have rook to c4 if
you capture the a4 uh
pawn then rook a5 goes after the a7 pawn
so you don't want to do that so rook the
c4 instead going after the b4 pawn and
now a5 by lil again offering the b for
pawn but if you capture this then rookie
one rook to e7 rook captures here rook
captures here it's just complete mess so
instead we have king the c8 trying to
get the rook into the game at least via
the rook d8 move and now we have b5 so
just just pushing both on the king side
and on the queen side we rook to d8
finally we've developed the rook but
it's still it's still hard to imagine
that the bishop and knight will ever see
the light of day so here rook to e1 and
now we have rook to f4 going after the
bishop here king g2 defending and now h6
trying to
uh free up the king side somehow but
it's not happening king g3 now comes
rook to a4 going after the a5 pawn and
now just knight to e8 and again can uh
stockfish capture on a5 and most
certainly uh he cannot because if
captures then we're going to play knight
to d6 check and after let's say king b8
now we're going to play rook to c1 and
again it's such a disgusting position
for black there's uh really no no move
you can make here uh to give you an
example if b6 we can just play knight b7
fork the rooks and that's it white wins
if you capture the knight then it's rook
captures on d7 check and after the king
moves we're just going to capture this
with checkmate as well the bishop covers
b7 the recover c7 and that's checkmate
for you so instead after knight to e8 we
have knight to c4 uh and now comes rook
to e4 putting pressure on the knight and
now there are so many tactics working
here for white it's just even pointless
to continue this with black even though
black is still up a piece so here h
captures in g5 h captures on g5 and now
b6 here but
no move you play makes really makes a
difference if you want to sidestep the
fork we still play knight d6 we put
pressure on the knight after knight
captures rook captures on a4 and you are
again dead lost here there's nothing you
can do so after h captures and g5 we
have b6 now comes rook captures on c4
as you might have imagined rook captures
knight to d6 check we win some material
back king to b8 knight captures on c4
and b captures on a5 so finally white
grabbed the back of the piece but still
black is up upon but it doesn't really
matter all that much you still can't get
this bishop and knight into the game so
there are some games where you can't get
your bishop or the knight into the game
and then we feel very sad for that piece
but here both pieces is just um i mean
it's hard to look at so king f4 we have
a4 pushing the pass pawn but it yeah i
mean
who are we kidding king to e5 we have
rook to c8 attacking the knight and now
another slap in the face
rook captures on d7 offering the knight
on c4 uh if the knight is captured then
we just play rook b7 check and you can't
move to a8 because this will be
checkmate in a few moves so after the
king moves you're going to capture here
and it seems like you can you know just
start gobbling up pieces but these
pieces are never getting into the game
so you don't really care about them for
example if rook c5 king d6 rook captures
on b5 we can just play rook to e7 and
now all of these squares are covered
bishop covers b7 this is the threat of
checkmate there's nothing you can do
here if rogue b6 just bishop here and
that's it again you're getting
checkmated even if you give up the rook
for a bishop we still have a rook
against a bishop and knight that are
non-existent basically so here after
rook captures on d7 rook the c7 was
played trying to trade off a pair of
rooks but now king d6 just uh completely
brutal again offering the knight but uh
well uh
you have to capture it
there's no move you can make here so
here rook captures and c4 was played now
comes rook to b7 check again we said
that if you move the king rook b6 will
be checkmate once the rook blocks the
check from the bishop this is checkmate
so after this rook the b7 check king the
c8 displayed now comes rook captures on
a7 and now rook d4 check bishop to d5
again look at this all of these squares
are covered this is the threat of
checkmate and there is no move stockfish
has to give up the rook we have king
capture so now a3 pushing the pass pawn
but now king to c6 now we have king to
b8 you don't want to get checkmated but
now just rook captures on a3 we have
bishop to h7
and this is a beautiful position because
black has only two moves here you can
move the king to c8 but this ends in
checkmate of course so the king can't
move and your only other move in the
position is bishop to h7 the knight is
uh
wow
so bishop to h7 was played b6 now
there's no defense against the b7 and
checkmate uh uh bishop to g8 we have b7
bishop to h7 and here comes rook to a8
with checkmate so really an amazing game
and it really shows you how
uh if uh i mean if you saw a human
playing such a game you we would like
maybe imagine maybe uh you know once in
a lifetime adult anderson or maybe a
vaseline
on a really good day could maybe muster
up something like this but uh i mean it
it's very very hard to imagine so it
definitely is like poetry and it's one
of the reasons why uh engine games even
though some of you are against them and
don't like them uh they can be
incredibly incredible and the ones you
see something like this it's very very
hard to go back to human chest so that's
why i don't
show them all all that often but you
know from time to time when there's a
really good one like this then i will
most definitely show it
so yeah that's the game i hope you guys
enjoyed it i i enjoyed it uh
very very very much and deeply so
i'm very happy for myself uh and i would
like to thank pablo mohan
mulham hyaci miss sandra brennan john
mcnabb and thomas vettel for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon uh continuing to check up on
your wonderful suggestions such as this
one and whatever else is happening in
the chess world uh thank you all i will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day